hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde wir ihr alle wisst bin ich der
schlechteste horrorspieler der Welt ich
weiß nicht warum man sowas freiwillig
macht ich weiß noch nicht warum man ein
Horrorfilme geht im Kino warum bezahlt
man Geld dafür dass man sich fürchtet
allerdings spielen wir heute Pfeifen
Knights at Freddy's 12 Uhr
erste Nacht
wir haben einen neuen Job und arbeiten
in dieser Pizzeria
jetzt ruft an ne
muss ich irgendwas drücken ich habe
lange nicht mehr gespielt zuletzt vor
Jahren
also das hier ist unser Büro
wir haben hier eine Tür und wir haben
hier eine Tür links ist
und rechts ist auch nie okay sehr gut
wir können die Tür schließen dann kommt
niemand rein und wir können links die
Tür aufschließen dann kommt das auch
hören rein wir sehen unten links unsere
Power 93% dementsprechend wenn wir Licht
anmachen geht die Porsche schnell runter
wenn die Türen zu machen schnell runter
und der mein iPad
das sind die drei Figuren auf die wir
aufpassen müssen das ist die ganze
Pizzeria und wir packen weil wir sind
noch mal 92%, 91
wir müssen es bis 6 Uhr nachts schaffen
denn das ist unser neuer Job und wir
müssen auf die Pizzeria aufpassen keiner
von diesen Leuten von den dreien darf
sich von hier hinten Cam 1A über Cam 1b
1c keine Ahnung was hier zu uns
hinbewegen der leonsin war am Arsch
mittlerweile haben wir schon ein Uhr
nachts
wir sind 88 oh mein Gott
sind alle noch da boah ey ich bin da nur
aus Versehen mit der
kleinen Haze bekommen wie schreckhaft
ich bin und ich war auch gestern feiern
das heißt ich habe auch noch ein Kater
[Musik]
das ist auf jeden Fall unser
Arbeitsplatz wir haben eine wunderschöne
Beleuchtung in Form einer Glühbirne wir
haben ein bisschen essensrestige vorne
im Ventilator wir haben Bilder die
wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Kinder die
man hier zu Gast weil in der Pizzeria
gemalt haben im Spinnenweben und wir
haben rechts niemanden wir haben Links
auch niemanden sehr gut wir müssen
einfach nur darauf achten dass diese
drei dort bleiben es ist ganz einfach
gesagt
aber in der Zeit wo ich nicht gucke
können die sich bewegen das heißt jetzt
gerade können die sich bewegen schauen
wir mal sind alle noch da ganz entspannt
ganz entspannt dick mein Ziel ist es
heute die erste Nacht fertig zu machen
dass ich es schaffe bis 6 Uhr morgens
wir haben 1 Uhr nachts das seht ihr oben
rechts eingeblendet wir sind bei 81 oh
mein Gott jetzt habe ich hier schon
wieder drauf geklickt okay aber es ist
bisher nicht sie sind alle drei noch an
ihrem Ort die kooperieren aktuell mit
mir eine nachts ich weiß nicht wie
langsam die Zeit hier vergeht aber wir
können uns ja auch einfach mal
mathematisch ein bisschen einplanen 82
haben wir schon wir haben jetzt schon
bis 1 Uhr bis 2 geschafft wir müssen
noch bis drei bis vier bis fünf bis
sechs also wir haben ein dritte fertig
sind alle drei noch da ganz entspannt
ein Drittel haben wir und wir haben
jetzt 22 % von unserer Power verbraucht
das heißt mathematisch dürft ihr mir
schon 33 % verbraucht haben haben wir
nicht wir gehen Energiesparen vor Greta
tunberg wäre stolz auf uns wir werfen
einen kleinen Blick nach rechts dort ist
niemand und einen kleinen Blick nach
links dort ist auch niemand Licht
schnell wieder aus Zack und wir schauen
ob sich die drei noch dort befinden die
sind alle drei noch da ganz gespannt
ganz
easy peasy
Lemon squeezy
ich mache mir gar keinen Stress
allerdings würde ich sagen werfen wir
jetzt noch mal einen kleinen Blick hier
rein alle drei noch da ganz entspannt
wir können ja mal ein bisschen rum
gucken hier ist niemand niemand ist
unterwegs alle drei noch in ganzen Raum
ganz weit entfernt von uns
was hast du stimmt
alles gut alles gut sind bei 68%
. 83 die Hälfte haben wir wir haben die
Hälfte und wir haben erst 33 Prozent
verbraucht wir werden es
kommt jetzt Musik
Musik
alle drei noch da
warum ist das denn also ich meine es ist
ja auch einfach blöd ich meine wir
arbeiten in dieser Pizzeria warum machen
wir nicht einfach noch ein Licht an und
was ist das für ein komischer Boss dass
der sagt Mensch
brauchst du nicht
mehr Strom reicht hier die die 100%
[Musik]
okay
an die anderen beiden sind zum Glück
noch
ausgefallen
Mann
[Musik]
perfekt
oder was sind das sind auch noch so
Masken überall oh mein Gott okay wir
haben eine Cam 1A das ist der Bär der
ersten Ehrenmann der Bär ist ein
Ehrenmann er bleibt da der Bär ist ein
Ehrenmann alle in die Kommentare
schreiben der Bär ist dein Ehrenmann
erster okay er bleibt doch da alles easy
alles easy lemony er ist weg
er steht im allway er steht im hallway
hier hinten steht da
es steht dort
er steht im hallway er steht in der USA
was soll ich machen was soll ich machen
wir sind um 4 Uhr nachts wir haben noch
zwei Stunden vor uns der Bär ist ein
Ehrenmann du kannst auch gerne da
bleiben blöder Wolf oder was soll man du
bist der beste toll
ich bleibe hier drauf wir sind bei 85
ich bleibe hier drauf diese Cam darf
nicht ausfallen die darf nicht ausfallen
dann ist er direkt bei mir die westwork
Cam darf nicht ausfallen dann haben wir
diese Nacht geschafft und ich habe das
erste mal ein five nights at Freddy's
Video auf diesem Kanal hier hochgeladen
jahrelang habe ich das nicht gemacht
weil ich hasse eure Spiele ihr wisst
dass mein Herz dreht dreht durch bei
sowas dann ist das erste Mal dass ich
jetzt hochgeladen habe ohne dass ich
mich erschreckt habe also ich habe mich
erschreckt
scheiß drauf komplett tritt zu Tür zu
wir sind Power usage 26% haben wir noch
übrig eine Stunde 25% wir können
runterzählen so schnell geht das runter
24% komm 86 bitte noch eine Stunde diese
Stunde lang hier darf nichts passieren
ist hier einer oder ist das nicht ich
glaube hier ist keiner mehr wir haben es
geschafft
[Applaus]
direkt escape
ich bin raus ich schwitze ich schwitze
wie sonst was Leute Horrorspiele sind
nicht gemacht für mich ich habe eine
Nacht geschafft ich spiele dieses Spiel
nie wieder ihr wolltet alle dass das
wieder spiele ich habe es geschafft eine
Nacht ich spiel sie